It's great you learn about Bayes Rule.
And one of the things you use Bayes Rule a lot for is learning from documents,
or text learning.
And the methods they'll tell you about is often called Naive Bayes.
It's actually a misnomer,
it's not to be naive, not as in naive as Bayes Rule itself.
But that's the name.
Okay, so you're going to exercise this later in our practice exams using
Enron email data sets.
But I give you the gist of it.
Suppose we have two people, one is called Chris and one is called Sara.
And both people write a lot of email and for
simplicity I'll assume that these emails only contain three words, okay?
They contain the word love, the word deal, and the word life.
Same is true about Sara.
Obviously people use more than three words.
But this area here is a little bit small for 30,000 words.
The difference of these two people Chris and
Sara is in the frequency at which they use those words.
And just for simplicity let's say Chris loves talking about deals.
So 80% of his words or 0.8 are deal and he talks about life and
love for a bit with 0.1 probability so
if Chris a word in email he's going to 80 percent of the time use the word
deal and ten percent of the time use the word love or life.
Sara talks more about love, a little bit about deals, .2 and about life .3.
And again that's a simplified example.
What Naive Bayes allows you to do is to determine based on
a random email who's the likely person who sent this email.
Suppose says an email that goes as follows love life, and
you don't know who sent it but you'd like to figure that out.
Then you can do the space on base form and
suppose you leave a priori that it's 50% probability by Chris or by Sara.
So we'll say p of Chris equals 0.5.
That means the prior probability for
it being Chris is fifty percent and that immediately means,
because it is one of the two, that the probability of Sara is also 0.5.
So if you look at this intuitively, who's more likely er,
to have written this email?
Chris or Sara?
Just check one box